alright then let's start this thing well
hello hello NDC London people it's
really nice to see you all
firstly well done for coming to this
session good choice
I'm really pleased to see you are
clearly people of good taste so I'm
quite happy to be spending the next hour
with you so my name is Steve and I'm
very much looking forward to showing you
this thing blazer I'm sure some of you
have seen it before but let's find out
can you do your hands in the air thing
if you've seen blazer or razor
components something like that before
all of us like 3/4 of you at least
that's great and just out of interest
how many of you went to Dan Roth's talk
about razor components this morning
that's like about third of the room as
well ok good so you are going to see
some overlap with this talk but not too
much ok there's gonna be a lot of cool
new stuff as well ok so what is this
thing why we bothering to look at it you
know for those of you have not heard
about this before blazer is an
experimental single page application
framework from the asp net core team
where we're building on the ability to
run dotnet code inside a browser in
webassembly to give you the ability to
be more productive and happy than ever
before that's the idea ok so in this
talk I'm going to be showing you quite a
bit about how how it works you know how
you can build stuff with it what the
process of actually creating UI with
this thing is but there's also going to
be quite a big part of like why are we
doing this anyway what is the point of
this why should you care what is
changing in our industry that is
creating this new possibility anyway so
to set that context let's think a little
bit about how web development works
today ok so web development today you're
going to have some code that runs on a
server somewhere might be a server in
the cloud might be just some dusty box
that's under your desk or something like
that but it's going to run some code and
that code might be in dotnet my bein
Java might be node might be go it might
be something else but it's some code
running in a server but you don't just
want to write something in a server you
want to make some UI appear in someone's
web browser and how are you going to do
that well you're probably today going to
use one of these single page application
frameworks it's the most mainstream way
of building an entree
will you I and whether its angular react
view something else it's gonna be
running on the JavaScript runtime now
maybe you write your code in typescript
or flow or something else that compiles
to JavaScript but basically it's running
on the JavaScript runtime so it's gonna
look and feel like JavaScript which is a
little bit of a shame isn't it because
this means you've got these two
different worlds to try and make talk to
each other and not only that it's just
sad on a principle level because if as
an industry we've built all these
amazing languages and platforms why
can't we use them wherever we want why
are we limited to this one little
cluster of languages around javascript
in the browser wouldn't be better if we
could use anything we want anywhere we
want and that's the idea behind web
assembly web assembly is a way of
running any code you want inside a
browser doesn't have to be JavaScript
we'll talk about how this works
internally later in the talk but just
for now let's say this is a great way of
running whatever code you want and it's
supported in basically all browsers
including mobile browsers at least as of
about 18 months ago so we're in good
state with web assembly so if we can run
whatever code we want inside the browser
on web assembly that naturally leads us
to think well could we run net inside
the browser on web assembly and when we
found out that we can do that that
brings us very happily to Blaser
which is a UI platform built on top of
this stack so this is for you to build
your sophisticated UI's on top of dotnet
running inside a browser okay so would
anyone want to do that well would there
be any benefits what who should want to
do that why would we care so there are
potentially quite a number of advantages
to doing this versus traditional
approaches to building your web UIs and
I'm going to go through some of them but
you don't want to just hear me keep
talking about this you want to actually
see it for yourself presumably so I'm
going to show you some examples of each
of these things just now let's start
with the advantages of using the c-sharp
language inside a browser okay so I'm
going to switch over to a demo
application now and I've got this blazer
application here that I can start up and
run inside my browser okay so it's a
pretty traditional typical looking web
application it's got a couple of
different pages in there we've got
to do list we've got this thing where we
can fetch some weather forecasts from
the server and we can do some forward
backward client-side navigation and it's
all interactive so let's have Meg Blaser
profit okay so that's my to do us and
it's all working fine and it's
interactive inside the browser sort of
think you would normally use a
JavaScript framework to build but we're
not using javascript here at all so if
we have a look at what's inside our
solution here you'll see what we've got
is a bunch of CS HTML files which is
razor talked about that in a second and
besides that we've got CSS we've got
HTML and we've got traditional c-sharp
files but no JavaScript because we don't
need it because we've compiled dotnet
and we've we've run it in such a way
that it can run inside the browser okay
so what are these CS HTML files well if
you've done any OS p-nut development in
the last few years you'll be familiar
with CS HTML being RAZR files now razor
is a syntax for combining c-sharp and
HTML in one file in a way that they can
work together really nicely
so let me give you a couple of examples
of that ok so firstly how does this very
simple thing on the home screen work
it's just some static content so how do
we make some static content show up in
our blazer application well we make a
component Emblaze are all parts of your
UI our components the whole application
is a component pages are components
layouts of components groups of UI
elements they're all components its
components all the way down so that's
what each one of these CS HTML files is
and the simplest component is very
simple indeed it's just some markup just
static markup but what's this okay so up
at the top we've got this one special
thing which is ID Eric a directive and
the page directive says this is the
component that we want to use if the
user is on the home page and we're going
to display this static markup so that's
pretty simple okay what about the
slightly more interesting thing of this
to-do list okay where we can actually
enter some stuff and the UI up days well
let's look at the code for to-do list
there's quite a bit more in here but I
think we can understand this quite
easily let's go through it so firstly
we've got the page directive up at the
top again to control which URL we
respond to and ignore this stuff from
Annette down here we've got a functions
block and inside the functions block we
can put some code and since this is net
and we want to write this in c-sharp we
are writing some c-sharp curve right
here inside our component so how does it
work well we've got this text box here
which says whatever value enter we're
going to put this in this field called
new item text which is defined down here
okay and then this form says when you
submit it we're going to call this
method add item which is a c-sharp
method defined down here and we'll take
the item that you've just typed in and
we add it to our list of items which is
a list of string and then we want the
box to get cleared out so we'll set a
new item text back to null okay and then
all that's left to do is iterate over
all the items in our items list and for
each one
we'll just display it on the screen so I
hope you will agree that this is a
pretty simple way of writing interactive
UI okay very simple familiar components
based programming but with dotnet
combined with HTML alright so last one
that I want to show you as an example is
this one where we're fetching the list
of weather forecasts now this is to
demonstrate how we can interact with
some external services to get data and
if we look at the code in there you'll
see again we use this page directive but
we're also now using inject inject lets
us interact with s pinettes dependency
injection system so that we can get
services that are defined within our
application and in this case we're
getting an HTTP client so that we can
make some calls to fetch some data okay
now we'll ignore all this stuff for a
minute and let's look down here and we
can see that when this component is
first initialized it's going to
asynchronously do an HTTP GET request to
some endpoint to fetch some data now as
it happens it's just a static file that
I've gotten disk but it could be
anything it could be some dynamic code
that runs on the server and when the
response comes back we're going to
deserialize it as an array of weather
forecasts and I've defined the weather
forecast type right there so then we
want to display that on the screen and
if we wanted to we could do it in a
similar way
two other to-do list works we could have
a for each loop and we could say for
each item I want to make an HTML table
row and I'll display the contents in
that and that would work perfectly fine
but I wanted to make this a little more
interesting so I've got this component
called MDC list one earth is that well
you won't see that my application has
this attractive kind of purple theme and
this pretty list here well this is all
coming from the material design library
okay so this is to show you that in
blazer we can pull in component
libraries that have got ready-made
components for us so I've got this
material design components list and I
can pass my forecasts to it and I can
pass all these other little template
parameters that control how stuff get
displayed in the list there all right so
that shows us how we can use c-sharp in
a remarkably simple way to build
interactive UI but what's this next
thing then the net dotnet ecosystem how
can we make use of the dotnet ecosystem
inside a blazer application well
consider the following scenario okay
it's Monday morning you've been working
all weekend and you've made this weather
forecast thing and you excitedly show it
to your boss or some kind of business
analyst in your company and they go well
done code monkey you've done a good job
but there's one little thing that I need
from you I need to be able to export
this to excel so that I can do some
business analytics on it and your thing
are great at export to excel okay fine
I'm gonna make you a CSV file
I can I can output a comma separated
text file that's going to be good and
the business analysts will say no I
don't want a CSV file
I want a proper spreadsheet I want
colors I want conditional formatting
I want charts this is my life don't take
it from me okay I want a real
spreadsheet and you'll say Oh gray right
how we're gonna make real spreadsheet
and the answer to that is really easily
okay because you're a darknet developer
and you've got access to the whole
dotnet ecosystem and doing things like
making spreadsheets is super easy so how
are we going to do it right we're gonna
go and we're going to add a reference to
an external third-party package okay so
let's go to new get dog and we're going
to search for excel all right and what's
going to come back from there a bunch of
things that help us to work with excel
and if we look closely the one
that's got by far the largest number of
downloads five point eight six million
of them is this thing called EP plus so
you say okay it's got a lot of downloads
therefore it must be the right thing for
me to use so I'm going to install that
into my application right now and it
says okay accept some terms yep
great I don't want your readme thank you
and now I've got the power to make Excel
spreadsheets so what do I want to do
first
I want to make a button that appears the
bottom of the screen here for
downloading this as a spreadsheet so I
could use a traditional HTML button if I
wanted to but hey since I've got this
material design thing I'll use an MDC
button so that it looks good and then
Visual Studio says hang on
you want me to invoke this download a
spreadsheet well sorry but there is no
such thing and that's going to be a
problem so you'll say okay fine right
I'm going to create this download a
spreadsheet method that we're going to
invoke when they click the button okay
what am I going to do in there well I
better put some logic in it so you'll go
and you'll read the documentation for EP
plus and it will tell you that what you
need to do is new up an Excel package
and then you can do stuff like you can
add a forecasts tab into the list of
worksheets in this spreadsheet and then
we're going to say all right browser I
want you to download this thing as a
file called forecasts dot xlsx and the
contents will be the bikes from that
spreadsheet that we've just created on
the client in our application
so let's load that now let's see if when
I press this download button does it
download a real spreadsheet ok says ok
you're opening forecasts do you want to
open that in Excel is of course so I
choose yes and Excel starts doing all
its stuff and when that comes up
hopefully we'll get a forecast now it's
empty right there's nothing in our
spreadsheet because I didn't put any
data in it but we have got this
forecasts tab down here which starts to
show that we're on the right track so
what do we want to put inside our
spreadsheet so again you go back to the
EP plus Docs and you read how to go
about inserting data in search and we'll
decide that what we want to do is we
want to start this cell b2 b2 and then
we can use c-sharp link query to fetch
whatever data we want for our in memory
weather forecasts array and we can use
link expressions like where
f dot temperature is greater than
hundred a that one and okay so we've
fetched our data and we have put it
inside our spreadsheet okay but we can
do some more cool stuff than that let's
make this a little bit more interesting
so first let's add a computed column
here in our spreadsheet where we're
using this formula to calculate
temperature E and F based on temperature
C very good and let's also dump in loads
of code that you won't have time to read
that's going to set horizontal alignment
background color and bold fonts and
other things like that all right and
then finally just to really show off
let's put in a chart okay just because
that's what our business analysts really
want it so let's go back and try that
now so if I hit the download button then
again it's going to say you're opening
this forecasts spreadsheet and when that
comes up this time instead of being
empty we've now actually got our data
and it's got colors and it's got
formulas it's even got this completely
insane pie chart that shows but how much
of the temperature happens on each day
of the week whatever that means okay so
there we go
we've done a super job there of pulling
in a thing just an arbitrary third party
thing from the dotnet ecosystem and we
were able to use it inside our
application
all right last benefit full-stack what
on earth do we mean by that why is that
a relevant term in this context okay so
the application I've shown you so far is
a true client-side web application it
does not have any dependency on there
being net on the server at all you could
host this on a PHP site if you wanted
you could more realistically host it on
node or or some other kind of modern
framework or if you wanted to you could
export it all and you could deploy it to
github pages or to Azure blob storage or
to some other static file store there's
no requirement for there to be done out
on the server but what if you do have
done it on the server are there
potentially some advantages that you can
use to tie your front end and your back
ends together in a useful and
interesting way so let me show you I'm
going to close this project right now
and I'm going to switch over to a
different version of it that's almost
the same except this one is going to
be based on an a spinet core server so
let me just run it first so we can see
that this works and that's not in any
way what I wanted to run let's set this
thing as the start of project and we can
close all our windows there we go
alright so let's start this up now when
that comes up you'll see that it's
basically the same thing that we had
before it's got the same set of
components in it the same pagers the
same basic behavior so we've got all
this stuff but if we look at our source
code there's now three projects instead
of one we've got the client project
which is basically the same thing that
we had before so this is another blazer
client-side web assembly application
it's got the same set of pages and
components and stuff it behaves the same
as before but we've also now got a
server project and that is an asp net
core server and we can use that as a
place to put things like our back-end
data services that we want to invoke or
any other things that we need a server
for like authorization or you know
database access that sort of thing okay
and then finally and perhaps most
interestingly we've got the shared
project and this is a really basic thing
it's just a dotnet standard to our class
library which you can just put any code
in that you want to share between your
server and your client because I've set
up references from the client project
and the server project both to the
shared so they both get whatever code is
in there and as an example I've put the
weather forecast type in there so now if
I go and look at the forecasts on the
client here you'll see that before I had
the forecast defined as an inline class
here so the client was defining its own
weather forecast type but now it doesn't
it just gets that from the shared
project and similarly on the server the
endpoint that we're calling this sample
data controller weather forecasts thing
which is going to return the data well
it doesn't define weather forecasts
either it gets that from the shared
project so the point is whatever stuff
we want to share between server and
client we just stick it in here and it's
there and it's not just for data you can
also use that for bits of logic as well
here I've got some logic that computes
temperature Fahrenheit based on the sea
and I could also put in things like
validation rules or other business logic
that we want to share between client and
server in an incredibly straightforward
Manor okay so those are three ways in
which it can be really nice to build
this kind of application but there are
various other benefits that we could
talk about as well you know performance
dotnet core on the server is just about
the fastest mainstream web platform that
there is if you can check the
independent tech and power benchmarks if
you want to verify that sort of thing
yourself it's extremely fast we've got
we've always had the best-in-class
tooling pretty much Microsoft has been
well known for for having really
outstanding industry-leading tools in
Visual Studio with the intellisense and
debugging and all that kind of stuff so
you know all that stuff comes with that
and then finally in terms of stability
well in dotnet world the culture is
basically we assume that your projects
are going to be around for like five
years or ten years or something like
that so we try really hard to keep
things stable over that kind of period
and we're not just completely changing
what set of libraries you're supposed to
use every three months
now stuff does change sometimes but
generally it's a more stable world that
you might see in say JavaScript land
okay so that gives you some ideas about
what this stuff is all about but I
haven't really shown you much about how
it works
on the inside yet so the way this stuff
works is that we've got three
technologies stacked up on top of each
other making this sort of technology
cupcake that we're able to enjoy and
feel delighted by okay so at the bottom
of our technology cake we're building
this stuff on web assembly and I've said
to you already that web assembly is a
way of running whatever kind of code you
want inside a browser but how does that
work okay well web assembly is a
bytecode format that's what the spec is
it says that here's a way of describing
some programs in a low-level bytecode
and browsers are supposed to implement
support for executing yet and the good
news is they have implemented support
for doing that all the mainstream ones
including mobile ones have done that but
what does this bytecode look like you
may well never have actually seen the
bytecode itself or maybe you seen it but
you wouldn't really know how to create
it yourself so let's have a go I'm gonna
create a small web assembly application
right now well call it an application
might be a stretch
because it's going to be very very
simple okay and this has got nothing to
do with dotnet too
use blazer this is just going to be pure
webassembly on its own so that you can
understand that right so why I've got
here in this directory is a few files
including Fibonacci C I expect you can
probably guess what that does but let me
show you it's a simple C program that is
going to compute the Fibonacci sequence
which is just a series of numbers that
are defined mathematically it goes 1 2 3
5 8 and so on after that I can add but
that's how it works
and my primitive nachi function is
simply going to take the number of terms
that we want to print and it's going to
say ok as long as you've got some more
stuff to do then I'm going to print out
the current term I'll compute the next
one and I'll print it I'll compute the
next one I'll print it and so on until
we run out of things to do so that's
written in C and as you know C doesn't
normally run inside web browsers but
thanks to web assembly we can compile C
to web assembly and then run it so let's
have a go at that so I'm going to show
you these are the files that we've got
right now but I'm going to compile
Fibonacci see using the M script and C
compiler to produce something that can
run inside a JavaScript runtime okay so
that compiles it takes a few seconds and
when that's done you'll see we've now
got these two new files Fibonacci j s
and Fibonacci dot wasum wasum
webassembly is the actual binary
bytecode format so we can't read that
directly it's just binary stuff but I'll
show you what's in there in a second and
the J s1 is a wrapper file that is
enable that intends to help you load it
and run it inside the browser now that's
what I want to do I want to run it in my
browser so I've got this index.html pipe
file that I can load in my browser and
show you what's in there well it's
extremely minimal not really even valid
technically but it's going to work and
it's going to load this Fibonacci J s
file and then run it so let's set up a
little static HTTP server that I can use
to execute that stuff and then I'll go
back to my browser and I'll go to
localhost port 8080 and we'll have a
look in the browser console and we
should see that indeed it is actually
printing out those first 10 terms of the
Fibonacci series so we're running C
inside the browser but how does it work
what's going on really so we'll have a
look in the the debugger and
actually in order to make this easier to
understand I'm going to recompile this
with additional debugging support so I
am compiling in debug mode and I'm going
to admit source maps as well and once
I've done that and I go back into my
browser and reload you'll see now we see
Fibonacci see shows up in the dev tools
and if we click on that we can see our C
source code here which is it which is
the stuff that we're running and I can
even do things like set a breakpoint on
there so if I hit reload we'll now hit
the breakpoint and it appears that we're
stepping through C code that's executing
inside the browser which is pretty cool
but we're not really actually executing
C at all what we're really executing is
the web assembly bytecode and it's just
been mapped to this source code by the
source Maps so let's have a look at the
actual byte code we can see that in here
now normally the Wesen file on disk is a
binary file that you can't possibly read
but Firefox is kind enough to represent
it to us in this kind of human readable
format well I appreciate that you have
to be the right kind of human to read
this but I think that we are the right
humans to read this we can do this all
right
so what is inside this crazy-looking
thing well we can see it's got all these
function imports and exports but I don't
really know what that most of that stuff
is let's just search for print Fibonacci
okay so we can see here's our code this
is the thing that we were writing and
what does it do well all these
instructions what are they if you would
look closely you might see that that's
kind of similar to the dotnet
instruction language MS IL is so just
like MS IL it's a stack based virtual
machine that operates on a fixed set of
primitive types and so we can compile
whatever code we want to to this format
as long as you've got the right kind of
compiler for it and the sort of thing it
can do is it can do things like define
functions it can have locals it can do
loops it can do these numeric operations
like subtracting one and it can call out
to system functions like here is where
it's calling the print thing okay so
given that we can even set breakpoints
inside web assembly as well so let's do
a reload on there and we should see that
we've hit some
break points and we can start stepping
through the actual web assembly code as
well all right so I hope that somewhat
makes sense to you that that's what's at
the bottom of the stack here we're able
to compile stuff to this bytecode format
it then runs inside the browser and web
assembly is really fast one of the key
design goals for web assembly from the
beginning has been performance and
generally speaking code that's compared
to web assembly runs within a factor of
two of executing just natively if you
compile it to native x64 machine code or
whatever else that you're normally
target okay so that's the idea with web
assembly and given all that we might
think well right let's run some dotnet
on that how are we going to run down on
it well the obvious way to run not on
web assembly would be to somehow compile
the dotnet machine code the msi l2 web
assembly by code okay if we could
somehow do that then we could just run
it inside the browser so that would be
cool but that's not actually what we've
done what we've done instead is we've
taken a dotnet runtime and we've
compiled that to web assembly so we're
not compiling your code to webassembly
we've already compiled the runtime to
webassembly and the runtime that we've
compiled is in fact mono and you might
think why mono why did you why mono the
answer to that is that Microsoft has got
three net runtimes that we share right
now we've got the Donaire framework
which is the CLR we've got a dotnet core
core CLR and then we've got mono
and these all have different places and
different purposes the idea is that for
you as a developer you don't have to
care which of these things your code is
running on you code against dotnet
standard and your code is going to run
on any of them just the same but why did
we pick mono for this then well it's
because mono is our preferred net
runtime for portable client scenarios
Mona is a really portable code base and
so it was the by far the most practical
one for us to compile to web assembly so
that's what we've done and that is
something that the dotnet team so that
the mono team is committed to shipping
as a fully supported production runtime
so that you can run your dotnet code
inside the browser on web assembly ok
but how do
work right I've just told you that this
thing exists but I've not really shown
it to you so let me show you a little
bit of mono running in on top of
webassembly and I can show you that
inside the application that we've been
building already what are we actually
sending to the browser how does the
browser know to load mono and to execute
our dotnet code inside it let's have a
look at the HTML source code
alright so our HTML that we're sending
to the browser is just normal HTML it's
got a bunch of CSS and body tags and
things like that we've got this loading
animated progress bar which is just
static HTML that I've put in there but
nothing really interesting happens until
we get to the bottom here where we load
this javascript file components web
assembly is and that is something that's
built into blazer so when you create
your new project with blazer that thing
is already there you don't have to see
it we just know how to serve that and
that file is what knows how to start up
mono and load your application into it
so let's see what the browser is really
doing if we open up the network tab here
and I'm going to hit reload and then
we'll look closely at what stuff this
thing has actually sent down to the
browser so we send that initial HTML
that I just showed you and that contains
instructions to load various things like
CSS and then it loads components
webassembly j/s and that tells it to do
a few more things to start up your
application and importantly it loads
mono wasum and that's what I told you
we've done with mono we've compiled it
to a web assembly binary using M
scripting the same way that I compiled
Fibonacci dot C to awesome the same
thing has happened with the mono
codebase
to make this file ok and then once
that's been loaded we can load your
regular dotnet assemblies into it so
we're not compiling these two web
assembly they're just normal net dll's
that have been built by the normal
c-sharp compiler and we could load them
and run them inside the mono runtime
which itself is running on web assembly
right so you may be thinking hang on
you're loading an entire dotnet runtime
into the browser this is going to like
hundreds of megabytes or something how
big is this thing
and the answer to that is currently it's
about two megabytes so for a dotnet
runtime
he's small and we quite pleased with
that but at the same time we're not
pleased with that because two megabytes
is big for a webpage and there are a lot
of scenarios where you want your
application to be quite a bit smaller
than two megabytes maybe you are
building some kind of internal line of
business app and it doesn't matter to
you at all we hear a lot of customers
say like I don't care if it's 10 Meg's
that's fine with me but if you're trying
to do some public facing thing you
probably want it to be smaller so we're
working quite hard and the mono team is
working hard on finding ways of cutting
that size down but you know 2 Meg's is
where we've got to at the moment of
course this is all cached so if the user
comes back later they're not going to
fetch any of that stuff a second time I
only downloaded 227 kilobytes this time
and that's because I'm not even caching
various things to do with bootstrap and
other stuff you can make the size down
to kind of nearly zero when it's cached
but it's 2 megabytes if it's not cached
ok so that's how we're running mono on
top of web assembly final thing the
topmost and most delicious most layer of
our technology stack is blazer and that
is the UI framework that we've been
using so that is the thing that is
defining not only how our application
starts up but what all our components
are and how they're able to interact
with each other right so I've shown you
a bunch of components already but I've
only shown you some fairly simple ones
you're an advanced and ambitious kind of
group of people I think so wouldn't you
like to see some advanced components I
think you would so let's go through two
scenarios where we can build some more
interesting things with components ok
we're gonna start with something that
sounds very smart indeed templates and
generics how can we make some generic
template or two components well what I
want to show you is let's look at this
thing here I mentioned earlier that i'm
using this MVC list okay now what is
that and how could we make our own
special list components ourselves
doesn't remember what it looks like it's
displaying this attractively formatted
list with icons and subtitles and things
like that and that's all coming from
this external component library but what
if we wanted to do this ourselves what
if we didn't have MDC list let's get rid
of it and implement it ourselves shall
we
so and
to show you what the equivalent inline
code would be it's kind of scary
you're not gonna like the way it looks
but this is how it is if we wanted to
make this material design list just by
ourselves we'd create an unordered list
and we'd put this massive pile of
unpleasant-looking CSS classes on it and
then we'd say okay for each of the
weather forecasts will iterate through
it and then we'll make more and more
markup during which will display the
icon and the date and the temperature
and other things like that so let's see
if our homemade material design list
works just the same as the the
predefined one
so let's come back and reload and it
should render more or less the same
thing it's slightly different it's not
displaying the temperature in Fahrenheit
anymore but you know it's basically the
same thing I just didn't make it exactly
the same okay so we can do this
ourselves but once we've done this we
don't want to keep reinventing this
every time we want some way of reusing
this component over and over again the
general idea of a material design list
so how can we make our own list
component I'm gonna do that right now
I'm going to add a new item and I'm
gonna choose where as a view and I'm
going to call it super list all right so
what can I put in my super list well the
first thing is let's think about what
data our list is going to need we want
to be able to pass in the list of things
to be rendered okay so I'm going to
define a parameter on my list here a
parameter is just a property that's got
this special parameter attribute and I
can pass in an enumerable of weather
forecasts that we want to render and
then I'm going to put some initial
markup in outside this component and
it's going to be the same thing that we
saw before so it's going to have all
these CSS classes and it's going to say
for each one of the things I'm going to
display something and initially I'm just
going to display the date all right so
let's keep it simple to get started with
and then over here on the consumer side
let's get rid of all that markup and I
should see in intellisense if my
intellisense was alive it's there yeah
so I've got my super list here and I can
start making use of that okay but I want
to pass in the list of forecasts to it
so that's what I'm going to do let's
save that I'm going to rebuild and then
we'll check that we are actually using
our super list component
now remember sue palace only displays
the dates and it does so in a very basic
and rubbish fashion so we've got some
more work to do firstly I do not want to
display the dates in this format I want
to be able to customize the format so
what can I do here well I could have a
parameter where you pass in a format
string or something like that but I want
to be even more advanced than that I
want to be able to pass in some
arbitrary markup that describes the way
that the title is going to be rendered
to this primary text so I'm going to
define another parameter here and it's
going to be called title and the typing
of it might be a little bit unfamiliar
so it's going to be of type render
fragment that's a special type that
components know about and that
represents an arbitrary piece of user
interface so the person using the
component can pass in whatever markup
they want which can contain logic or
other components and we're able to
render it from here so now instead of
just rendering item date I'm going to
invoke title and I'm going to pass the
item into it
it's a generically typed render fragment
which operates on a weather forecast so
I'm going to call it and so will render
whatever markup has been passed in for
each item and now if I go back onto the
consuming side here I should be able to
specify a title okay and I can put in
here whatever I want to using this magic
keyword context okay and if I type that
correctly like let's make sure I've got
the type correct and I try to type
context then intellisense should say
okay I know what that is that is going
to be a weather forecast so I'll prompt
you with what all the properties that
are on weather forecasts okay so I want
to display the date and I want to be
able to display it in a particular
format so I'm going to pass a format
string here to control that it gets
rendered like this right let's try this
out let's see if we now rendering our
dates in a more attractive format so we
reload and indeed we are now displaying
it in the way that we wanted okay but I
don't just want to display the date I
want to display things like an icon and
summary text and other things like that
so I'm going to go back to my super list
and I'm going to say you can pass in as
many different templates as there are
things to do useful stuff with so I'm
gonna say we're gonna have an item icon
template a subtitle and actions and
we're going to make use of all those in
the rendered output so let's get rid of
this and I'm going to just paste in a
big chunk of stuff that displays the
icon and the title and the subtitle and
all that stuff okay and then back over
here on the caller side I can now pass
not just a title but I can pass all the
other stuff the icon the summary I'm
displaying the temperature in this
particular format that I'm controlling
over here when I use my super list okay
let's try this one more time
reload and now we should see okay great
it's looking good we're displaying the
icons we've got these things over here
on the right we've got pretty much only
usable list but it's not completely
reusable yet because at the moment is
completely hard-coded to work with
weather forecasts what about if we want
to rather render other things that are
not weather forecasts and this is where
generics come into it so generic
components are very very cool you can do
this I can say I want to declare a type
parameter and that's just like a generic
parameter on a c-sharp class and so now
instead of using weather forecast I'll
say okay give me an enumerable of T
items and also a bunch of templates that
in a strongly typed way operate on T
item okay and now I can render anything
I want so then I can go back over here
to where I use it and I can specify what
I want T item to be so let's say I want
T item to be a weather forecast all
right so now I can pass this list of
weather forecasts in and v/s knows that
each one of these things is going to be
a weather forecast so we get the right
intellisense okay but what's cool is
still then that is what if we don't
specify what the type it is well that's
great too because we've got generic type
inference we don't have to specify what
it is the fact that the parameters we've
passed give us enough information to
know what the generic type is means that
it's just going to work anyway so we
still have all the correct
intellisense showing up
we are very happy people okay last thing
we might want to do is it's a bit
strange that we've got this word context
here but what is that why is that the
right word so let's say we want to
change that for something else let's say
I want the variable to be called
forecast instead and now vs is going to
say to us what is this context thing
you're speaking of I don't know what
that is but I do know what forecast is
because forecast is now the name for
each item here so I can change all these
contexts to forecast and the code starts
to make a lot more sense so we've pretty
much completely recreated everything
that we had in the MDC list component
and we've made our own reuse of a list
it's not limited to working with weather
forecasts it can work with anything all
right so that's one type of advanced
component let me give you another one
what about this cascading stay what is
that it also sounds pretty advanced
right so all the components I've shown
you so far
they contain their own state they just
deal with their own little world and
they don't have to interact with other
components in any way but what if you
need to have a way of coordinating stay
across all the different components in
your application well there are many
ways you can do that because this is
just a dotter application you can use
whatever patterns you want with c-sharp
and events and statics or dependency
injection whatever it is that you want
to do but Blazer or components the
underlying UI technology have got a good
feature for this that help you to
coordinate stay across your application
so as an example of that let's imagine
that I want to make my application fee
mobile I've got this purple button here
but what if I want it to be different
colors at certain times and I don't want
all my components to embed information
about themes I want to just define that
in a central place so I'm going to add a
new class and I'm gonna call it theme
info and I can put whatever properties
on here I want to represent stuff that I
can theme and what I'm going to put in
is just this one thing call button class
I could put more stuff in if I wanted to
but that'll do for now all right and now
I want to be able to pass an instance of
this to all the components in my
application so I could do this wherever
I want but I'm going to go to my main
layout
and I'm going to say okay I'm going to
use this built-in thing called cascading
value and that can provide a value to
all the parts of my UI that are inside
this element and v/s is saying what do
you want me to pass you haven't said so
I'm going to say what I want to pass is
not that what I want to pass is this I
want to pass a new theme info okay so
I'm creating a theme info and I'm saying
the initial button class is this button
warning thing and I'm passing that to
all the other parts of my application
and so then I can receive a theme info
wherever I want to I'm going to go over
to my to-do list which we saw earlier
and I'm going to make a parameter where
I can get that current theme now as you
know normally we use parameter to get
parameters but this is not a normal
parameter this doesn't just come from my
parent this comes from anywhere in the
hierarchy above me so I'm going to have
a cascading parameter and so we can get
the current theme cascading down through
the UI and then up here on my button
instead of using button normal I'm going
to use current theme button class so
whatever it is that's on my theme so
let's build that now okay I'm going to
come over and hit reload and so now
instead of that purple button you can
see we've got a different colored button
because that's coming from the theme
which we've been sharing so that is how
we can supply static content but
cascading value is cool because it's not
just static stuff we can pass but also
stuff that changes so let's say I want
to make this button class change I'm
defining it as a field with an initial
value of button normal and I'm going to
use that and then so that the user can
edit it I'm going to put in a drop-down
list and it's going to be wired up to
that button class so whatever you choose
from here that's going to be the value
for this field and there's a few
different options that we can use okay
so now if I start my application again
the button is going to go back to being
purple because that was our default
theme but if I change it here I can have
orange or I can have blue and that theme
information just automatically gets
distributed through my application I
don't have to think about subscribing
for changes or anything like that
the
is able to flow correctly throughout my
tree of components great so there we go
there's two advanced scenarios for
components now that's all very well but
this is stuff that we've already shipped
if you've been using Blazer for the last
few months you've probably already seen
that stuff and what you maybe you would
like to see is stuff that we have not
shipped yet what's coming soon what are
we working on all right so I'm gonna
show you a few things now so let's start
with debugging now we've already got
some debugging support we can already do
some debugging in a browser if you're in
dance talk early this morning you will
have seen that I'm gonna do a very quick
recap of what we've already got just for
anyone who hasn't seen them so I'm gonna
switch over to Chrome because that's the
browser we're supporting debugging in
right now and I'm just going to make
sure that I've cleaned my application
and I'm gonna rebuild it everything to
give me the best chance of success here
and then I'm going to start my
application up when it's rebuilt and
then hopefully I'm going to show you how
we can do some debugging inside the
browser so I'm going to go over to
Chrome and I'm going to start my
application up and I think all right how
am I going to do this debugging then
because I can't really use vs because vs
doesn't know about chrome you know in
web application up webassembly
applications and I can't really use the
browser dev tools because they only show
me things to do with CSS and JavaScript
and things like that so how can I do bug
dotnet code well
we've set up a debugging server that
runs with your application that the
browser can connect to in order to get
information about what your application
is doing and if we look here it tells us
use this debugging hotkey shift alt D
alright so let's try it as su happens if
I press shift D well it opens a new
window and it says ah it's not going to
work because the debugging server can't
connect to your browser just yet because
you're not listening for debug
connections in this browser so what you
do is you copy this thing that it tells
you about and close your browser start
it up using the instructions and then
this time hopefully the debug server
will be listening so if I press this tab
here and then I start it up then
hopefully I can actually see not just
the usual stuff that I see not just the
assess on the HTML but also the files
from my project the sea shark files like
here and even the CS HTML files like
here okay and what's more I can set
breakpoints so let's say I put a
breakpoint here when we try to add an
item to our to-do list and just so we
can see let's split the windows and then
I'll try to add an item here and when I
do it hits the breakpoint inside the
browser so that's pretty cool right
we're able to do some net debugging
inside the browser very good but this is
old news this shipped months ago
wouldn't it be nice if there was a way
of doing the same debugging but not
inside the browser but where your surf
code actually is inside Visual Studio
that's not been a thing that we've had
support for but would be nice wouldn't
it so let's see if we can make it work
shall we I want to make Visual Studio
connect to this browser so I'm going to
copy the URL and I'm gonna do attach to
process and I'm gonna choose the chrome
dev tools protocol and I'll put in the
URL of my application and v/s will go
and look and I'll say oh yes I've seen
that you've got a blazer application
running side the browser there so let's
do that shall we so I'll double click on
this thing and v/s will say what kind of
code would you like to debug and you'll
say well I'll choose the only thing that
you'll give them the option to so I
don't know why asking me and then I'll
choose ok and now es is connected to
with the browser and so now I'm going to
try putting a breakpoint on my c-sharp
code here inside the IDE and then I'll
type something in blue and then I'll
click my button and we've paused
Brewed bizarrely it says Visual Studio
code but if I switch over here is
actually hit the breakpoint inside my
IDE so we've now got the IDE connected
to the dotnet runtime running on web
assembly inside the browser and we can
actually debug ok so there's some things
about debugging work right now but most
of them don't as an example of something
that does work we've got this very cool
thing where we can show you the call
stack that goes across different
language types so if we look at the
bottom you can see that when I click
that button it's started by hitting it a
javascript event inside component
webassembly j/s that's how we know that
the event happened it goes through
various layers inside javascript it then
goes through various layers inside
webassembly before it finally lands on
my c-sharp code so you can debug calls
that go from c-sharp into JavaScript or
from JavaScript back into c-sharp and
you can step through the the chains of
calls that go across languages like that
so that works really nicely but most
other things don't work we're working on
it
and we will get some nice debugging as
we go forwards okay so that's where
we're going next with debugging right
can we make our applications start up
any faster well isn't it fast enough for
you already let's have a look okay let's
go to my home page here and let's see
how long it takes for my application to
start so when I hit this button we can
see that it does that sort of progress
bar thing which is a bit weird but it is
doing it and the reason why it takes
about one second for it to start up is
because this is the time where we're
fetching mono and we're starting it up
and we start on your application up and
so we have to show a progress bar while
that's happening but you may think you
know what would be way cooler than a
progress bar what the user would like to
see instead of a progress bar the actual
application if you don't mind that would
be way cooler so how could we do that
then well we've got these components
right and they run on web assembly they
run inside a browser and they don't out
components and we've got a dotnet server
so if you think about it couldn't we run
these components on the server as well
and then we could render the application
on the server get its initial rendered
HTML send that to the browser and then
while the web assembly stuff is starting
up the users already seeing the
application UI that would be a lot
better than a progress bar let's see if
we can do that then so I'm gonna go over
to the thing that defines my HTML okay
you saw this in the browser earlier you
saw this is where we've got this static
HTML progress bar I do not want to see
this progress bar anymore what I want to
see instead of that is my actual
application getting rendered so I can
say all right then we're going to render
a component asynchronously and the
component I'm rendering is my entire
application because remember components
are everything your whole application is
a component the pages of components
layers governor's everything's a
component and I've got a component
called app which is the whole thing and
that's what I want to render for
whichever page you're currently on ok so
let's see if this does its job correctly
so now I'm going to press reload and
let's see if we see a progress bar this
time we do not see a progress bar that's
a little better
how fast is this thing starting up let's
go to a new browser tab I'll put in the
URL
I'll hit go and boom my UI pause
strangely there but let's try that one
more time and then boom it's really
quick okay no progress bar the
application just comes up it's still an
interactive application because we've
loaded the web assembly stuff in the
background okay and if you want to
quantify how fast this stuff is really
getting rendered on the server let's
have a look inside the browser Network
tab here and I'm going to hit reload
again okay right then let's have a look
you'll see that we are rendering that
initial HTML there in 26 milliseconds so
that is pretty fast that is a lot faster
than that 1 or 2 seconds that we were
waiting before and the actual overhead
of rendering your razor components is
really close to zero if you return a
page that just returns HelloWorld is
basically the same so the performance is
really something I'm extremely happy
with so that is doing server-side
pre-rendering to make your application
start up near instantly
even while the web assembler stuff is
loading in the background and one of the
cool thing that you can do with that
although I don't know maybe you'll think
this is not cool but I kind of think
it's cool in a sort of retro old-school
way is what if we wanted to make a
traditional server rendered application
now we didn't want any of this web
assembly stuff let's just delete that
script tag completely what's going to
happen now okay let's find out so I'm
going to go to this weather forecast
page here which is was already running
when I hit reload it's not going to load
any web assembly stuff at all now this
is a pure server rendered application
like a traditional MVC server-side
application that just returns HTML to
the browser if I look here it looks kind
of disgusting so we haven't sorted out
all the formatting yet but if you look
closely this is the HTML markup that all
the components are generating so it's a
pure server rendered HTML application
now and some parts of it still work for
example any links HTML links still work
so I can navigate backwards and forwards
through this list but other things will
not work for example my navigation menu
will not work because that is built with
an interactive component so if you
wanted to you can use components for
pure server-side rendering if you want
but honestly that's not the best thing
to do best thing is to make them be
interactive as well okay right then last
thing can we make our code run faster
well is it not fast already how fast is
it should we try and have a way of
quantifying how fast our code is
actually executing well that's why I've
got this thing here called primes
alright and we are going to be able to
compute prime numbers all right let's
get the tenth prime number that's twenty
nine let's get the thousandth prime
number okay that's have the ten
thousandth prime number it's like a
hundred thousand something and it's
taken as three hundred and sixty
milliseconds to compute that okay why
did it take that long well let's have a
look at the code for this I'm going to
look at this component called Prime's
and it's got this text field while you
type in which prime you want it's got a
button that's going to submit to this
calculate method here and calculate is
going to call a method on a library that
I've written called super maths and that
is maths not math for the Americans dot
Prime's compute n Prime okay and if we
look at the code inside that it's a very
very brain-dead simple algorithm it's
just going to do absolute brute force
it's going to consider for all the
numbers is it prime by checking all the
possible divisors and then you know
we're just going to keep doing that
until we get to whichever one that you
asked for very very simple and quite
computationally expensive and we see
that it takes about 350 milliseconds
here now if we compare that in running
it natively how fast is it going to be
so to find out I've created a normal
console app here called normal console
app and if we look in the program main
of that you'll see it calls the same
thing it calls the same compute and the
prime thing so let's set that as I start
a project and run it and see how fast
this stuff really should be okay
it should be able to do this in like 12
or 13 milliseconds if it's running under
JIT compiled native code and so it's not
super honestly that it's taking 360
milliseconds we've got this slight
factor of
20 or 30 slow down going on there and in
fact it's significantly worse still if
we go over into chrome let's see what
it's like here in chrome world okay
let's make sure I've got my application
started up give me the ten thousandth
prime please go and waiting oh okay so
it's done it but it's taken a rather
terrifying almost two seconds to do that
why is it so slow then the reason this
is so much slower is because when we're
running your dotnet code on the mono web
assembly runtime
we're actually interpreting yet we're
not yet compiling it because this is
something that is extremely difficult to
do under web assembly maybe we'll get
there that's not what we're doing yet
all right so this might seem kind of
terrifying that we've got such a massive
slowdown now as for how much of a
problem this is it depends what kind of
app you're building we've designed
blazer to be able to produce really rich
and sophisticated you is that up day
faster than humans can perceive it even
when you get to very complex you eyes so
I'm reasonably confident that you can
build something big and complex and your
users are just going to regard it as
being updating instantly because we've
got this very optimized UI code path but
if you want to do something CPU
intensive obviously it's not such a rosy
scenario but there are ways that we can
make this better so what if instead of
running on an interpreter we were able
to compile your dotnet code to bare
metal web assembly ahead of time and
then execute that in the browser instead
of running it through an interpreter and
that is something that the mono team has
been hard worker for quite a while and
they're pretty close to being ready with
this so I'm going to show you a little
example right now this is just a proof
of concept that's separate from what the
mono team has done just to give you an
idea of what the developer experience
might be like so I'm going to look at my
project file here for my app document
that's the blazer application here and
you can see that this is where we're
referencing super maths and I'm going to
put a little bit of extra instructions
here to say when we reference that I
don't want to load it as a dotnet diello
I want to ahead of time compile it okay
and then just because this is a hacky
prototype I've put together I'm going to
have to go to my index CS HTML and put
in a reference for this other thing
the a RT loader that that I've made all
right so now when we compile this the
application is going to be a little
different because some of it is going to
be ahead of time compiled so let's
reload here inside the browser and I'm
going to look inside the browser dev
tools here because what I want you to
see is that if we look in this framework
directory with all the web assembly
stuff we've not just got mono des
awesome
we've now also got super maths awesome
where we've compiled the dotnet assembly
to native bytecode and if I look at that
okay so I have to refresh to see it but
if i refresh then we look in there you
can see this is the web assembly
translation of our dotnet code and we've
exported this function and compute F
Prime and the implementation of it in
just native web assembly has been
generated right there okay but is it
actually any faster shall we find out so
let's say if I want the 10th prime well
that's text in no time at all by the
time we've got it running if we've that
want the 10,000th Prime is it still
going to take 300 milliseconds it now
takes 1819 milliseconds so we've had a
fantastic speed increase very very close
to the 1314 milliseconds that we're
getting running natively and in fact
it's even better if we go over into
Chrome and we try to get that one there
so give me the ten thousands Prime and
it's going to come back in ten
milliseconds so it's actually faster
than running natively now well not
really okay that's this hugely
misleading the most biggest way in which
this is misleading is I'm running in
debug mode here if I ran with release
optimizations the native one would be a
bit faster but not much faster so my
point with this is not to say which one
is faster out of web assembly or native
the point is just to say that with a RT
compilation it's completely reasonable
for your dotnet code to run
approximately the same speed or within
the ballpark of the same speed of
running natively so you can do super CPU
intensive stuff if you want to though
hopefully you don't even need to if
you're just doing UI stuff ok so there
is some stuff that is coming soon that
we have not shipped yet okay so we're
getting close to running out of time now
I'm just going to give you a quick
overview if you weren't down to talk
this morning you saw this before these
components that we're building their
designs
work in multiple environments so I've
shown you these components running
inside the browser on web assembly
updating the Dom directly we've got a
feature that's going to a spinet core
300 which is a you know a committed
shipping production thing where you can
run the same components that work under
web assembly and you can execute them on
the server in an interactive mode where
all of the execution lives on the server
and the browser doesn't see any web
assembly at all and all the updates take
place over a real-time WebSocket
connection which is super if you want to
make a very thin client so you've got
low end devices that you want to run
your components well you run them on the
server and you just to push the UI
updates over the channel it gives you
access to the full dotnet runtime and
could simplify your code in various ways
it also has some drawbacks like you
can't do this offline the client-side
applications can work truly offline if
you want them to but the ones that run
on the server they can't because you
know it's using the server to actually
update the UI if you've also got the
latency between the you know the browser
and the server and you're using up your
server resources but pros and cons and
they're good for different scenarios the
final thing the final case where you can
run these components that's not client
side or server side you might be
thinking what hang on client side and
server side that's the whole universe
isn't it there's not there's no other
side to this but there is another side
to it which is what if you want to write
a native desktop application with
something like electron well you can run
the same components there as well and we
can update the applicant the UI directly
inside electron it give you a very rapid
example of that we did a little work
exercise to try porting the Azure
storage Explorer application to run
inside blazer on electron so this is the
Asha storage blacks pleura and it is a
blazer the set of blazer components
running inside electron so we've used
the same web technologies that you see
me use and we can make something that
say you know looks and feels just like a
native application we've got this grid
with a hundred thousand rows in air
we've got tabs we've got native
right-click menus we can do network
access we can interact with things like
operating system services so for example
let's see what Andrew nurse has been put
into these blob stores
open this item here and that's going to
show up as a you know inside the native
windows image editor so we can interact
with the operating system properly from
electron so point I've shown you all
that is this component model that we're
giving you now is designed to be
incredibly flexible it can run under web
assembly it can run on the server it can
run on electron and your same UI
components can work in all of those
places so that is all I'm gonna have
time to show you if you want to try out
blazer I'd recommend you do surf there's
a lot to learn
we've got some documentation site
there's lots of good community projects
that are springing up around blazer and
the whole a spinet core components
system so you should go and try them out
to do that you should go to blazer
dotnet and that give you all the
instructions about how to set things up
and you can try that out and you know
make yourself a happier and more
productive person so that's all hope you
enjoy the rest of the conference
remember to evaluate this session
[Applause]